زياره ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى المحطه الثانيه ضمن جولته
الاسيويه كوريا الجنوبيه اختتمت باعلان
صفقات واستثمارات تتجاوز قيمتها عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات لتاخذ البلدين الى
درجه اعلى من التقارب الاقتصادي والتجاريه
خلال الزياره عقد الامير محمد بن سلمان
جلسه مباحثات اولى مع رئيس الوزراء هاندا
سو تناوله فيها سبل تعزيز العلاقات
والتعاون المشترك في مختلف المجالات ثلاثه
جلسه مباحثات رسميه عقدها ولي العهد
السعودي بحضور وحزين من البلدين حيث كان
على راس الوفد الكوري رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
يونس يوكيو اكد خلال هذه الامير محمد بن
سلمان على عمق العلاقه وان كوريا الجنوبيه
تعد شريكا استراتيجيا للسعوديه على مدى
الستين عاما الماضي
مرور 60 عاما على انشاء هات بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وجمهوريه كوريا مما يؤكد
رغبه بلدينا في الاستمرار في ترسيخ اسس
هذه العلاقه التاريخيه والعمل على استكمال
الجهود الراميه الى تعزيز التعاون في جميع
المجالات
مستقبل استثماري ضخم بين الرياض وصول حيث
جرى خلال الزياره ابرام 25 عقدا ومذكره
تفاهم بقيمه 29 مليار دولار وضمن جدول
زيارته لتقى ولي العهد السعودي عددا من
رؤساء كبرى الشركات الكوريه واستعرض معهم
فرص الاستثمار في التكنولوجيا والصناعه
والتشييد والمدن الذكي تعاون وثيق جمع
البلدين ضمن اطار الرؤيه السعوديه الكوريه
2030 وتنسيق استثماري عالا عزز من الشراكه
الممتده لسته عقود